the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
all right so let's let's begin lecture
six we're talking today about
Exponential's Exponential's and
logarithms and these are the last
functions that I need to introduce the
last standard functions that we need to
connect with calculus that you've
learned about and there as certainly as
fundamental if not more so than
trigonometric functions so first of all
we'll start out with a number a which is
positive which is usually called a base
and then we have this these properties
that a to the power 0 is 1 that's how we
get started and a to the power 1 is a
and of course a squared not surprisingly
as a times a etc and the general rule is
that a to the x1 plus x2 is a to the x1
times a to the X 2 so this is the basic
rule of exponents and with these two
initial properties that that defines the
exponential property the exponential
function and then there's an additional
property which is deduced from these
which is the composition of exponential
functions which is if you take a to the
x1 power to the X to power then that
turns out to be a to the x1 times x2 so
that's an additional property that we'll
take for granted which you learned in
high school now in order to understand
what all the values of a to the X are we
need to first remember that if you're
taking a rational power that is the
ratio of two integers power of
eight that's going to be a to the M and
then we're going to have to take the nth
root of that so that's a definition and
then when you're defining a to the X so
a to the X is defined for all X by
filling in so I'm going to use that
expression in quotation marks filling in
by continuity this is really what your
calculator does when it gives you a to
the power X because you can't even punch
in the square root of x it doesn't
really exist on your calculator there's
some decimal expansion so it takes a
decimal expansion to a certain length
and spits out a number which is pretty
close to the correct answer but indeed
in theory there's an a to the power
square root of two even though the
square root of two is irrational and a
to the PI and so forth all right so
that's the exponential function and
let's draw a picture of one so we'll try
say Y is equal to two to the x here and
I'm not going to draw such a careful
graph but let's just plot the most
important point which is the point zero
1 that's 2 to the 0 which is 1 and then
maybe we'll go back up here to minus 1
here and 2 to the minus 1 is this point
here this is minus 1 1/2 a reciprocal
and over here we have 1 and so that goes
all the way up to 2 and then
Exponential's are remarkably fast so
it's off the board what happens next
out at 2 it's already above my my range
here but the but the graph looks
something like this all right now I've
just visually at least and graphically
filled in all the rest of the points you
have to imagine all these rational
numbers and so forth so this point here
would
would have been one too and so forth all
right so so that's that's not not too
far along so now what's our goal well
obviously we want to do calculus here so
our goal here for now and it's going to
take us a while we have to think about
it pretty hard is to calculate what this
this derivative is all right so we'll
get started and the way we get started
is simply by plugging in the definition
of the derivative the derivative is the
limit as Delta X goes to zero of a to
the X plus Delta X minus a to the X
divided by Delta X that's that's what it
is
and now the only step that we can really
perform here to make this into something
a little bit simpler
is to use this very first rule that we
have here that the exponential of the
sum is the product of the Exponential's
so we have here a to the X so what I
want to use is just the property that a
to the X plus Delta X is equal to a to
the X a to the Delta X and if I do that
I see that I can factor out a common
factor in the numerator which is a to
the X so we'll write this as the limit
as Delta X goes to 0 of a to the x times
this ratio now a to the Delta X minus 1
divided by Delta X
so far so good we're actually almost to
some serious progress here so there's
one other important conceptual step
which we need to understand and this is
a relatively simple one we actually did
this before by the way we did this with
sines and cosines the next thing I want
to point out to you is that you're used
to thinking of X as being the variable
and indeed already we were discussing X
as being the variable and a is being
fixed but for the purposes of this limit
there's a different variable that's
moving X is fixed and Delta X is the
thing that's moving so that means that
this factor here which is a common
factor is constant and we can just
factor out of the limit it doesn't it
doesn't affect the limit at all a
constant times the limit is the same as
whether we multiply before or after we
take the limit so I'm just going to
factor that out so that's my next step
here a to the X and then I have a limit
Delta X goes to 0 of a to the Delta X
minus 1 divided by Delta X all right and
so what I have here so this was by
definition the derivative so here is d
by DX of a to the X and it's equal to
this expression here now I'm going to
now I want to stare at this this
expression and and and see what it's
telling us because it's telling us as
much as we can get so far without some
so first let's just look at what this
says so what it's what it's saying is
that the derivative of a to the X is a
to the x times something that we don't
yet know and I'm going to call this
something this mystery number M of a so
I'm going to make the label M of a is
equal to the limit as Delta X goes to 0
of a to the Delta X minus 1 divided by
Delta X all right so this is a Defen
so this mystery number M of a has a
geometric interpretation as well so let
me let me describe that it has a
geometric interpretation and it's a very
very significant number so let's let's
work out what it is so first of all
let's rewrite the expression in the Box
using this shorthand for this number so
if I just rewrite it it says D by DX of
a to the X is equal to this factor which
is M of a times a to the X so the
derivative of the exponential is this
mystery number times a to the X so we've
almost solved the problem of finding the
derivative of a to the X we just have to
figure out this one number M of a and we
get the rest so now let me first so let
me point out two more things about this
number M of a so first of all if I plug
in x equals zero that's going to be d by
DX
a to the X at x equals zero according to
this formula that's M of a times a to
the zero which is of course M of A so
what is M of a M of A is the derivative
of this function at zero so M of a is
the slope of a to the X at x equals zero
of the graph the graph of a to the X at
zero so again over here if you looked at
the picture I'll draw the one tangent
line in here which is this one here and
this thing has slope what we're calling
M of two so if i graph the function y
equals two to the X I'll get a certain
slope here if i graph it with a
different base I'll maybe get another
slope and what we've got so far
is the following phenomenon if we know
this one number
if we know the slope at this one place
we'll be able to figure out the formula
for the slope everywhere else now that's
actually exactly the same thing that we
did for sines and cosines we knew the
slope of the sine of the cosine function
at x equals zero the sine function had
slope 1 the cosine function had slope
zero and then from the some formulas
well that's exactly this kind of thing
here from the some formulas this some
formula fact is easier than the ones for
sines and cosines from the some formulas
we worked out what the slope was
everywhere so this is we're following
the same procedure that we did before
but at this point we're stuck we're
stuck because that time using radians
this very clever idea of radians in
geometry we were able to actually figure
out what the slope is whereas here we're
not so sure what M of two is for
instance we just don't know yet so the
basic question that we have to deal with
right now is what is is M of a that's
what we're left with and the curious
fact is that the clever thing to do is
to beg the question so so we're going to
go through a very circular route here
that it's circuitous not circular
circular is a bad word in math it means
that one thing depends on another and
that depends on it maybe both are wrong
circuitous means we're going to be going
taking a roundabout route and we're
going to discover that even though we
refuse to answer this question right now
we will succeed in answering it
eventually all right
so how are we going to beg the question
what we're going to say instead is we're
going to define a mystery base or a
number E
as the unique number so that M of e is
equal to one alright that's the trick
that we're going to use we don't yet
know what E is but we're just going to
suppose that it that we have it now I'm
going to show you a bunch of
consequences of this and also I have to
persuade you that it actually does exist
so first let me explain what the first
consequences first of all if M of E is 1
then if you look at this formula over
here and you write it down for e you
have something which is a very usable
formula D by DX of e to the X is just e
to the X all right so that's an
incredibly important formula which is
the fundamental one is the only one you
have to remember from what we've done so
maybe I should have highlighted it in in
several colors here
all right that's a big deal
all right very happy and again let me
just emphasize also that this is the one
this is the one which at x equals 0 has
slope 1 that's the way we defined it all
right so if you plug in x equals 0 here
on the right hand side you get you get
one slope one at all right so that's
great except of course since we don't
know what E is this is this is a little
bit dicey so next I just
even before explaining what he is in
fact we won't get to what he really is
until the very end of this lecture but I
will have to persuade you that ye exists
all right so we have to have some
explanation for why we know that there
is such a such a number
okay so first of all let me start with
the one that we supposedly know which is
the function to to the X we'll call it f
of X is 2 to the X all right so that's
that's the first thing and remember that
the property that it had was that F
prime of 0 was M of - that was the
derivative of this function the slope it
at at x equals 0 of the graph of the
tangent line that is so now what we're
going to consider here is some Cayenne
II kind of stretching we're going to
stretch this function by a factor K any
number K so what we're going to consider
is f of K X now if you do that that's
the same as 2 to the K X right but now
if I use the second law of exponents
that I have over there that's the same
thing it's 2 to the K to the power X
which is the same thing as some base B
to the X where B is equal to so let's
just write that down over here B is 2 to
the K all right so whatever it is if I
have a different base which is expressed
in terms of 2 by being of the form 2 to
the K then that new function is
described by this function f sub F f of
KX the stretch now so what happens when
you stretch a function that's the same
thing as shrinking the x axis so when K
gets larger this this gets this
corresponding point over here would be
over here and so this corresponding
point would be over here so you shrink
this picture and the this slope here
tilts up so as we as we increase K the
slope gets steeper and steeper let's see
that explicitly numerically here
explicitly numerically if I take the
derivative here alright so the
derivative
with respect to X of B to the X that's
the same thing as well that's the chain
rule right that's the derivative with
respect to X of F of KX which is what
it's K times F prime of KX and so if we
do it at 0 we're just getting K times F
prime of 0 which is K times this M of 2
so how is it exactly that we cook up the
right base B so so B equals e
when K is equal to the 1 over this
number in other words we can pick all
possible slopes that we want we just
this has the effect of multiplying the
slope by a factor and we can shift the
slope at 0 however we want and we're
going to do it so that so that the slope
exactly matches one the one that we want
so we still don't know what K is we
still don't know what E is but at least
we know that it's there somewhere yeah
how do I know well f of X is 2 to the X
if f of X is to the X then the formula
for F KX is this I've decided what f of
X is so therefore there's a formula for
F of KX and furthermore by the chain
rule there's a formula for the
derivative and it's K times the
derivative of F so again scaling does
this by the way we did exactly the same
thing with the sine and cosine function
if you think of the sine function here
let me just remind you here what happens
with the chain rule you get K times
cosine KT here so the fact that we set
things up with it's beautifully with
radians that this thing is but we could
change the scale to anything such as
degrees by the appropriate factor K and
then there would be this scale factor
shift of the derivative formulas
but of course the one with radians is
the easy one because the factor is one
the one with degrees is horrible because
the factor is some crazy number right
like 180 over PI or something like that
okay so there's there's something going
on here which is exactly the same as
that kind of rescaling okay
so so far we've got only one formula
that I'm going to which is a keeper here
this one all right we have a preliminary
formula that we still haven't completely
explained which has got a little wavy
line there and we have to fit all these
things together okay so now to fit them
together I need to introduce the natural
log
so the natural log is denoted this way
Ln of X so maybe I'll call it I'll call
it a new new letter name we'll call it w
is equal to log X here but if we were
reversing things if we started out with
a function y is equal to e to the X the
property that it would have is that it's
the inverse function of e to the X so it
has the property that the log of y is
equal to X all right so this defines the
log now the logarithm has a bunch of
properties and they come from the
exponential properties and in principle
you remember these and I'm just going to
remind you of them so the main one that
I just want to remind you of is that the
logarithm of well the logarithm of x1
times x2 is equal to the logarithm of x1
plus the logarithm of x2 and maybe a few
more are worth reminding you of one is
that the logarithm of 1 is 0 a second is
that the logarithm of e is 1 all right
so these correspond to the inverse
relationships here if I plug in here x
equals 0 and x equals 1 if I plug in x
equals 0 and x equals 1 I get the
corresponding numbers here y equals 1
and y equals e and maybe it would be
worth it to to plot the picture wants to
reinforce this so here I'll put them on
the same chart if you have here e to the
x over here it looks like this
then the logarithm which I'll maybe put
in a different color so this crosses at
this all important point here zero one
and now in order to figure out what the
inverse function is I have to take the
flip across the diagonal x equals y so
that's this shape here going down like
this and here's the point 1 comma 0 so 1
comma 0 corresponds to this identity
here that the log of 1 is 0 and notice
so this is log X the graph of log X and
notice that it's only defined for X
positive which corresponds to the fact
that e to the X is always positive so in
other words this white curve is only in
the is only above this axis and the
orange one is to the right here it's
only defined for X positive all right oh
one other thing I should mention is the
slope here is 1 and so the slope there
is also going to be 1 now what we're
allowed to do relatively easily because
we have the tools to do it is to compute
the derivative of the logarithm so to
find to find the derivative of the log
we're going to use implicit
differentiation this is how we find the
the derivative of any inverse function
so remember the way that works is if you
know the derivative of the function you
can find the derivative of the inverse
function and the mechanism is the
following
you write down here W is equal to log X
all right here's the function we're
trying to find the derivative of W but
now we don't know how to differentiate
this equation but if we exponentiate it
so that's the same thing as e to the W
is
Oh 2x all right right because let's just
stick this in here e to the log X is
equal to X all right now we can
differentiate this so let's let's do the
differentiation here we have D by DX e
to the W is equal to D by DX of X which
is 1 and then this by the chain rule is
D by DW e to the W DW DX product of
these two factors that's equal to 1 and
now this guy is the one little guy that
we that we actually know and can use
that's this guy here all right so this
is e to the W DW DX which is 1 and so
finally DW DX is equal to 1 over each of
the W but what is that it's X so this is
1 over X all right so what we've
discovered is and now I get to put
another green guy around here
is that this is equal to 1 over X
all right so now we have two companion
formulas here the rate of change of log
X is 1 over X and the rate of change of
e to the X is is itself is e to the X
and it's time to return to the problem
that we having a little bit of trouble
with which is somewhat not explicit
which is this M of a times X we want to
now differentiate a to the X in general
not just e to the X so let's work that
out and I want to explain it in a couple
of ways so you're going to have to
remember this because I'm going to erase
it but what I'd like you to do is so now
I want to teach you how to differentiate
basically any exponential so we'll
so now to differentiate any exponential
there are two methods they're
practically the same method they have
the same amount of arithmetic but you'll
see both of them and they're there
they're equally valuable so we're going
to just describe them so method one I'm
going to illustrate on the function a to
the X so we're interested in
differentiating this thing exactly this
problem that I still didn't solve yet
okay so here it is and here's the
procedure the procedure is to write so
the method is to use base E or convert
to base e so how do you convert to base
e well you write a to the X as e to some
power so what power is it is e to the
power log a to the power x and that is
just e to the X log a all right so we've
made our conversion now to base e the
NEX 'pn enchi love something so now I'm
going to carry out the differentiation
so d by DX of a to the X is equal to D
by DX of e to the X log a and now this
is a step which causes great confusion
when you first see it and you must get
used to it because it's easy not hard
okay the rate of change of this with
respect to X is let me do it by analogy
here
say I had eetu the 3x and I were
differentiating it the chain rule would
say that this is just three the rate of
change of 3x with respect to x times e
to the 3x the rate of change of e to the
U with respect to u alright so this is
the ordinary chain rule now what we're
doing up here is exactly the same thing
because log a as frightening as it looks
with all three letters there is just a
fixed number it's not moving it's a
constant so the constant just
accelerates the rate of change by that
factor which is what the chain rule is
doing so this is equal to log a times e
to the X log a alright same business
here with log a being or replacing 3 so
this is something you've got to get used
to in time for the exam for instance
because you're going to be doing a
million of these all right so do get
used to it alright so here's the formula
on the other hand this expression here
was the same as a to the X so another
way of writing this and I'll put this
into a into a box but actually I never
remember this particularly I just read
arrive it every time is this is the
derivative of a to the X is equal to log
a a to the X right now I'm going to get
rid of what's underneath it here so you
alright so this is another another
formula now so there's the formula I've
essentially finished here and notice
what is the magic number
the magic number is the natural log of a
that's what it was we didn't know what
it was in advance this is what it is
it's the natural log of a let me
emphasize to you again something about
what's going on here which has to do
with scale change
so for example the derivative of with
respect to X of 2 to the X is log 2
times 2 to the X the derivative with
respect to X these are the two most
obvious bases that you might want to use
is log 10 times 10 to the X so one of
the things that's natural about the
natural logarithm is that even if we
insisted that we must use base 2 or that
we must use base 10 we still would be
stuck with natural logarithms they come
up naturally they are the ones which are
which are independent of our human
constructs of base 2 and base 10 the
natural logarithm is the one that comes
up without reference and we'll be
mentioning a few other ways in which its
natural later here okay so I have two I
told you about this first method now I
want to tell you about a second method
here so the second method is called
logarithmic differentiation logarithmic
differentiation alright so how does this
work well sometimes you're having
trouble differentiating a function and
it's easier to differentiate its
logarithm that may seem peculiar but
actually we'll give several examples
where this is clearly the case that the
logarithm is easier to differentiate
than the function ok so it could be that
this is an easier quantity to understand
so we want to relate it back to the
function U so we have to so I'm going to
write it a slightly different way so
let's write it in terms of primes here
so the basic identity is the chain rule
again and the derivative of the
logarithm
well maybe I'll write it out this way
first so this is would be d of log u du
u times D by DX of U okay these are the
two factors and that's the same thing so
remember what the derivative of the
logarithm is this is what is it 1 over u
so here I have a 1 over u and here I
have a d u DX so I'm going to encode
this on the next board here which is the
sort of the main formula that you always
need to remember which is that log u
prime is equal to u prime over u ok
that's the that's the one to remember
here yeah the question is how did I get
this step here alright so this is the
chain rule okay the rate of change of U
with respect to AAG you with respect to
X is the rate of change of loggia with
respect to u times the rate of change of
U with respect to X that's the change
all right so now I've worked out this
this identity here and now let's show
how it handles this case D by DX a to
the X let's do this one so in order to
get that one I would take U is equal to
a to the X all right and now let's just
take a look at what log U is log U is
equal to X log a right now I claim that
this is pretty easy to differentiate
again it may seem hard but it's actually
quite easy
so maybe somebody can hazard a guess
what's the derivative of x log a X log a
it's just log a right so this is that
same thing that I was talking about
before which is if you've got 3x and
you're taking its derivative with
respect to X here that's just three
that's the kind of thing have here again
don't be put off by this massive piece
of junk here it's a constant all right
so again keep that in mind it comes up
regularly in this in this kind of
question all right so there's our
formula that is the derivative of the
logarithmic derivative is this but let's
just rewrite that right that's the same
thing as u prime over u which is log u
prime is equal to log a right so this is
our differentiation formula so here we
have u prime u prime is equal to u times
log a if I just multiply through by U
and that's what we wanted that's d by DX
of a to the X is equal to log a I'll
reverse the order of the two which is
customary times a to the X all right so
this is this is the way that logarithmic
differentiation works it's the same
arithmetic as the previous method but we
don't have to convert to base e we're
just keeping track of the exponents and
doing the differentiation on exponents
and multiplying through at the end ok so
so now I'm going to do two trickier
examples which illustrate logarithmic
differentiation
again these could be done equally well
by using base e but I but I won't do it
method want a method to always both work
right so here's a second example again
this is the problem when you have moving
exponents but this time we're going to
complicate matters by having both a
moving exponent and a moving base all
right so we have a function U which is
well maybe I'll call it V since we
already had a function U which is X to
the X a really complicated looking
function here so again you can you can
handle this by converting to base e
method one but we'll do the logarithmic
differentiation version all right so I
take the logs of both sides okay and now
I differentiate it and now when I
differentiate this here I have to use
the product rule this time instead of
having log a a constant I have a
variable here so I have two factors I
have log X when I differentiate with
respect to X I differentiate with
respect to this factor here I get x
times the derivative of that which is 1
over X okay so here's my formula almost
finished so I have here V prime over V
is equal to I'm going to multiply these
two things together I'll put it on the
other side because I don't want to get
it mixed up with log X plus 1 the
quantity alright and now I'm almost done
I have V prime is equal to V times 1
plus log X and that's just D by DX X to
the X is equal to X to the X times 1
plus log X
all right that's that's it so these two
methods always work for removing
exponents
so the next thing that I like to do is
another fairly tricky example and this
one is this one is not strictly speaking
within calculus although we're going to
use the tools that we've just described
to to carry it out in fact it will use
some calculus in the very end all right
and what I'm going to do is I'm going to
evaluate the limit as n goes to infinity
of 1 plus 1 over N to the power n so now
the reason why I want to discuss this is
this is a this is it turns out to have a
very interesting answer and it's a
problem that you can approach exactly by
this method and the reason is that it
has a moving exponent the exponent n
here is changing and so if you want to
keep track of that a good way to do that
is to use logarithms so in order to
figure out this limit what we're going
to do is we're take the log of it and
figure out what the limit of the log is
instead of the log of the limit those
will be the same thing so we're going to
take the natural log of this quantity
here and that's n log 1 plus 1 over N
and now I'm going to rewrite this in a
form which will make it more
recognizable so what I'd like to do is
I'm going to write n or maybe I should
say it this way Delta X is equal to 1
over N all right so if n is going to
infinity then this Delta X is going to
be going to 0 so this is more familiar
territory for us in this class anyway so
let's rewrite it so here we have 1 over
to X and then that is multiplied by log
of 1 plus Delta X all right so n is the
reciprocal of Delta X now I want to
change this in a very very minor way I'm
going to subtract zero from it so that's
the same thing so what I'm going to do
is I'm going to subtract log of 1 from
it that's just equal to zero right so
this is not a problem and I'll put some
parentheses around this alright now
you're supposed to recognize all of a
sudden what this thing
what pattern this fits into this is the
thing which we need to calculate in
order to calculate the derivative of the
log function okay so this is in the
limit as Delta X goes to 0 equal to the
derivative of log X where well the base
point is x equals 1 that's where we're
evaluating that's the X 0 that's the
base value now this is the difference
quotient that's exactly what it is and
so this by definition tends to this
limit here but we know what the
derivative of the log function is the
derivative of log function is 1 over X
so this limit is 1 ok so we got it we
got the limit and now we just have to
work backwards to figure out what this
limit that we've got over here is
so let's do that so let's see here the
log approached one so the limit as n
goes to infinity of 1 plus 1 over N to
the N so sorry the log of this yeah
let's read it this way so this is the
same thing as well the thing that we
know is the log of this right 1 plus 1
over N to the N and goes to infinity
that's the one that we just figured out
but now this thing is the exponential of
that so it's really to this power here
so this guy is the same as the limit of
the log of the limit of this thing which
is the same as the limit log of the
limit the limit of the log in the log of
the limit or the same log limb equals
Lin log ok so I take the logarithm I
take the exponential that just just
undoes what I did before and so this
limit is just 1 so this is e to the 1
and so this limit that we want here is
equal to e so I claim that with this
step we've actually closed the loop
finally because we have an honest
numerical way to calculate e there first
there are many such but this one is a
perfectly honest numerical way to
calculate e we we had this e we didn't
know exactly what it was it was this M
of e there was Ma the logarithm and so
on we have all that stuff but we really
did need to nail down what this number E
is and this is telling us if you take
for example one plus one over a hundred
to the hundredth power that's going to
be a very good perfectly decent anyway
approximation to e so this is a
numerical approximation which is all we
can ever do with this kind of irrational
number
and so that closes the loop and we now
have a coherent family of functions
which are actually well defined and for
which we have practical methods to
calculate okay so see you next time